un busard cendré dans le ciel de la
petite bosse il survole les parcelles
d'orge et de blé à la recherche de
petits mammifères pour ces oisillons
tout en surveillant son nid installé au
sol ça fait des knicks ont pas très très
gros ça peut faire un trou comme ça en
fait dans la parcelle et la femelle va
venir déposer directement au sol entre 3
et 5 e qu'elle va couvé pendant trois 3
4 semaines à peu près ensuite les deux
parents vont venir nourrir les jeunes
jusqu'à leur envol d'ici là les moissons
auront eu lieu une saison de tous les
dangers pour les petits bizarre alors
chaque année une campagne de protection
est menée pour tenter de sauver les
nouveau-nés à l'aide de cages provisoire
malheureusement si on ne fait rien en
cinq ans on aurait la perte de ces
oiseaux qui a créé cette z ps sur ces
trois buzaré busard cendré est bizarre
saint martin le busard des roseaux
donc si on ne fait rien on détruit et on
perd toute une population de rapaces sur
la bouche leur disparition serait aussi
une calamité pour les agriculteurs qui
tirent bénéfice de la présence de ces
rapaces amateurs entre autres de petits
rongeurs y va il va vraiment de pouvoir
imprimer réguler les populations de
micromammifères et aider les
agriculteurs pour éviter tout ce qui est
ravages sur les cultures les choses
comme ça premier concerné donc les
céréaliers sont incités à favoriser le
maintien de la population des busards à
l'aide de couverts végétaux
l'idée en fait c'est leur proposer un
certain mélange d'espèces alors que ça
peut être du sorgho maïs
houde et les puces des légumineuses
voilà donc c'est un ensemble un mélange
qui y voit ensuite implantés sur sur
leurs parcelles et ça va être des zones
de nourrissage par exemple pour des
busards ou des zones de refuge 38 couple
de busards cendrés ont été observées
cette année sur les soixante mille
hectares de petites bosses c'est plus
que l'an dernier